und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
drei hurra und ein kleines Lächeln
bis dahin war es ein sehr ernst
blickender König der der heute vor den
Augen der Welt gesalbt und gekrönt wurde
guten Abend zum heutigenal eine über
zwei Kilo schwere Krone auf dem Kopf und
das Wissen dass das Standing der
Monarchie kein Selbstläufer ist das kann
schon auch als Last empfunden werden
auch wenn man 74 Jahre lang darauf
vorbereitet wurde und darauf gewartet
hat wer sich die Krönungszeremonie heute
angesehen hat konnte jedenfalls eine
Vorstellung davon bekommen wie Könige zu
den Zeiten als sie tatsächlich noch
Herrscher waren das Publikum
beeindruckten erst den herlein berichtet
aus London
[Musik]
es hatte von Anfang an wohl kaum Zweifel
gegeben dass dies ein außerordentliches
Spektakel werden würde
[Musik]
Glanz und Gloria das können die Briten
nun mal zur Perfektion und wann könnte
man das besser zur Schau stellen als bei
der Krönung eines Monarchen da gibt es
vergoldete Kutschen mit Juwelen besetzte
Kronen und edelrogen
eine Kirche so mit Gesang fühlen dass
auch den letzten irgendwann ein Gefühl
der Rührung überkommt ist auch
weitgehend Teil des Plans
[Musik]
gesalbt wurde der König mit Öl aus dem
Heiligen Land der heiligste Moment des
krönungszeremoniells geschützt vor
unerwünschten Blicken
dann der Augenblick da Charles III vom
Erzbischof von Canterbury die Krone
aufgesetzt bekam
auch Königin Camilla wurde gesalbt und
gekrönt nur ein bisschen Flotte als ihr
Ehemann
laute Jubelschreie des Volkes ließen
sich nicht vernehmen als der König die
Abby verließ aber das mochte vielleicht
daran liegen dass es aus
Sicherheitsgründen zu weit weg war und
die Glocken so laut läuteten
mit der Präzision eines Uhrwerks setzte
sich kurz darauf die Prozession von der
Westminster Abbey in Richtung Buckingham
Palast in Gang mit Kutschen eben vielen
Pferden noch mehr uniformierten
hunderttausende sollten die Straßen und
Parks eindrücklicher Beweis dafür dass
Glanz und Gloria immer noch ziehen
wollen wir einen gewählten Präsidenten
nein mit was würde man dies ersetzen
wenn du diese Musik dort hörst niemand
kann das so wie wir man schauen sich nur
all diese Leute an wir machen das
perfekt das ist meine persönliche
Meinung ich kann aber auch andere
verstehen die das übertrieben finden
doch dass das Vereinigte Königreich
eines ist das nicht nur aus Royalisten
besteht unterstrichen diese
Protestierenden und das Großbritannien
inzwischen ein Land ist das verschärfte
demonstrationsgesetze hat die Tatsache
dass einige von ihnen aufgrund des
Spruchs nicht mein König tatsächlich
getötet wurden dann zum krönenden
Abschluss die traditionelle Balkonszene
mit der königlichen Familie dabei konnte
man sich des Eindrucks nicht erwehren
dass das alles ein wenig aus der Zeit
gefallen wirkte noch mehr als die zweite
weltkriegsmaschinen die bei solchen
Gelegenheiten gern aus dem Hangar geholt
werden wegen des schlechten englischen
Wetters diesmal aber nicht starten
konnten stattdessen flogen nur moderne
Jets über die frisch gekrönten heute und
die Köpfe der Normalsterblichen hinweg
dann schalten wir noch zu unserer
Korrespondentin in London Hilke Petersen
Hilke das war jetzt Glanz und Gloria des
alten Empire dass du heute zu Schau
gestellt wurde aber die Realitäten im
Vereinigten Königreich sind ja
eigentlich andere oder
ja wie geht es dem Königreich von
Charles dem dritten es geht im
landwirtschaftlich nicht gut siehe es
erlebt massive streikquellen seit sehr
langer Zeit das ganze Berufsgruppen
demoralisiert zurücklässt
das staatliche Gesundheitssystem nhls
droht in Teilen zu kollabieren und
politisch ist es in den einzelnen
Landesteilen extrem schwierig in
Schottland etwa kämpft die regierende
SNP darum sich auseinander zu brechen
nach einem massiven Finanzskandal gucken
wir nach Nordirland dort verweigert die
unionistische die Europe unsere
Regionalparlament einzuziehen seit über
einem Jahr aus Protest gegen mit der EU
gefunden der Handels und grenzregeln das
bedeutet das ist ein Landesteil der
unregiert ist und ohne Haushalt da steht
tatsächlich und der britische
Premierminister Richie sonak steht eine
ausgelaugten Partei vor sie ist
geschwächt durch brexit Kämpfe und durch
Experimente mit Premierministern wie
Boris Johnson und List Trucks es hat in
den letzten Tagen hier lokale Wahl en
gegeben da haben die Tories die
Konservativen deutlich verloren Leber
ist im Aufwind und hofft darauf dass sie
vielleicht bei den Wahlen irgendwann im
Laufe des nächsten Jahres ein
Regierungswechsel herbeiführen können
danke Schönke nach London
eine Art Krönungsmesse gab es heute auch
in Nürnberg die CSU führte Markus Söder
zu ihrem Spitzenkandidaten für die
Landtagswahl im Oktober mit quasim
monarchischem Ergebnis unangefochten
wobei man sich bei Markus Söder
natürlich immer ein bisschen fragt ob
das Ministerpräsidenten da sein für ihn
immer noch der Traumjob ist der für ihn
mal war hat man erstmal nach einer
Kanzlerkandidatur gegriffen wird
vielleicht selbst der Freistaat Bayern
nicht mehr ganz so prächtig sollte es so
sein dürfte er sie das aber natürlich
niemals anmerken lassen Stefan leifert
berichtet
am Ende als die parteitagshalle schon
durchgefegt wird gibt es noch dieses
Bild Markus Söder ganz buchstäblich
bemüht das Image der One-Man-Show zu
brechen mehr Team mehr Themen mehr
zwischen Töne der CSU-Chef versucht
heute einen kleinen Schwenk ich bin
hoffentlich reifer geworden in der Zeit
vielleicht doch gelassen natürlich macht
man bei der Fehler aber es jedem Fehler
lernt man ich sitze mehr das habe ich
gelernt mir auf Team als je zuvor doch
die Regie dieses Parteitags spricht eine
andere Sprache ist ganz allein auf einen
ausgerichtet
per Handzeichen und mit 100% kürt die
CSU ihren Vorsitzenden zum
Spitzenkandidaten ich gratuliere uns
dazu ich bedanke mich bei Euch und
wünschen uns heißt CSU eine starke
Zukunft vielen Dank
nun ist die Landtagswahl ganz allein
seine Wahl in 100 Minuten Rede hat Söder
sich mehr als sonst durch Bayern Themen
gekämpft wahlkampfschlager aber sollen
Attacken auf Ampel und Grüne werden
heute die gleichen Affäre das ist nichts
anderes als grüne Korruption habe ich
muss reichen entlassen sonst ist die
Verwandten Affäre greifen eine Affäre
Habeck und ich sag das mal deutlicher
manche Grünen im Bayerischen Landtag
wenn ihr noch einmal das Wort Filz
ernsthaft in den Mund nimmt löst eure
eigenen Probleme anstatt ratschläger den
anderen zu geben
die Grünen einst Traumpartner sind so
das Hauptgegner in diesem Wahlkampf
Wagners Gendern Klima Kleber alles was
grün ist oder sich so anfühlt wird Söder
zum deftigen Feindbild zusammen ein Teil
der politischen Klasse redet so einen
Unsinn und scharf scheiß das kann doch
nicht der Ernst von Verantwortung
kompetent sein oder
das ist im Grunde dieser Hinweis wir
hören genauer hin als die ampelparteien
sind und das ist im Grunde auch dieser
Vorwurf die ampelregierung insgesamt
Berlin sei viel zu weit weg von dem was
die Leute tatsächlich bewegen würde
damit versucht man zu punkten die
Umfragen sind gerade gut für die CSU
über 40 Prozent die Kritik an Söder
vorerst verstummt natürlich ist es ja so
dass wie soll man sagen man nicht mit
jeder Position auch immer einverstanden
ist das ist aber gerade bei
erfolgspartei immer der Fall man muss
immer gar nicht lieben wenn er gute
Arbeit macht dann muss er dadurch
überzeugen die CSU kann sehr ungenädig
sein wenn ihre Vorsitzenden nicht
liefern die eigentliche Bewährungsprobe
des Markus Söder steht noch bevor
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist zu Besuch in
Kenia das Land das all die Afrika
Schönheiten bietet die Touristen suchen
Elefant Zebra und Co aber Safari steht
für den Kanzler nicht auf dem Programm
er kommt als Handelsreisender grüne
Energie sind es die ihn interessieren
und für die der afrikanische Kontinent
ein gewaltiges Potenzial bietet
etwa am Rift Valley dem großen
afrikanischen Grabenbruch der sich von
Afrika 6000 Kilometer bis nach Asien
zieht entstanden durch die Abspaltung
der afrikanischen von der arabischen
Kontinentalplatten was der deutsche
Kanzler dort zu sehen bekam berichtet
Susann von Lojewski
es ist die Kraft der Erde die im
kenianischen graydrift Valley ihre
Zeichen setzt überall im großen
Grabenbruch kommt Wasserdampf aus der
Erde
geothermiedes Wasser steht das größte
geothermiewerk Afrikas eukaria beim
Aufbau hat die deutsche Förderbank KfW
mit günstigen Krediten über 215
Millionen Euro geholfen hat
Energiequelle ist grün und erneuerbar
sie ist nachhaltiger als viele andere
Energiequellen und Deutschland war uns
sehr behilflich in diesem Bereich
den Beschluss gefasst ausschließlich auf
erneuerbare Energien zu setzen bis 2030
will man bei 100% sein ein Vorbild für
Deutschland auch deshalb ist der Kanzler
nach Kenia gekommen Zeit für Ausblicke
auf die herrliche Landschaft gibt es
kaum Olaf Scholz will etwas von Afrika
lernen
dass man seine natürlichen Gegebenheiten
nutzen soll ist sicherlich das was wir
hier ganz konkret sehen wir haben keine
vulkanischen Regionen wie diese hier in
Deutschland aber wir haben sehr viele
Gegenden und Landschaften in den
Geothermie gute natürliche
Voraussetzungen hat deutsche Ingenieure
haben auch bei der Planung des
kraftwerkzeugkaria geholfen demnächst
soll es erweitert werden auch Äthiopien
zeigt an der Technologie Interesse
erdwärme ist nahezu eine unerschöpfliche
Quelle und der Kanzler will das
Potenzial auch in Deutschland nutzen es
wird sehr groß eingeschätzt deshalb
werden jetzt auch all die Geodaten
zusammengetragen und alle Informationen
gesammelt damit der Mut wächst solche
Untersuchungen zu machen mit moderner
Technologie haben wir auch die
Möglichkeit dass wir besser feststellen
können ob Bohrungen auch erfolgreich
sein werden Kenia will aber auch den
Ausbau einer anderen Ressource
vorantreiben Sonnenenergie denn die
anhaltenden dürren machen es Wasserkraft
schwer lassen Staudämme Austrocknen der
Klimawandel kann auch erneuerbare
Energien versiegen lassen warnen
Experten
wenn wir tagsüber Solaranlagen auf
Dächern laufen lassen dann ist das viel
effizienter man kann mehr Strom auf
weniger Fläche erzeugen man spart das
Wasser in Staudämmen bei großer
Trockenheit und kann es dann am Abend
nutzen
bis Deutschland einmal von den
natürlichen Ressourcen Kenias
profitieren kann wird es dauern doch es
geht um Zusammenarbeit und darum die
globalen Herausforderungen zu bewältigen
Nachrichten von Wolf
auf Vermittlung der USA und
Saudi-Arabiens haben die
Konfliktparteien im Sudan Gesprächen
über eine Waffenruhe zugestimmt vertrete
bei der Seiten sind dazu heute in
Saudi-Arabien eingetroffen gleichzeitig
gingen die Kämpfe im Sudan weiter mehr
als 120.000 Menschen sind bereits in
Nachbarländer geflüchtet so wie hier per
Fähre über den Nase Staudamm nach
Ägypten das UN-Flüchtlingshilfswerk und
Ägyptens Rote Halbmond erwarten noch
mehr Flüchtlinge wenn sie den Menschen
helfen möchten hier die Möglichkeit beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
IBAN die
65-100
400-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Sudan da der Angaben finden Sie auch auf
spenden.zdf.de und auf ZDF Text Seite
das russische Außenministerium macht die
Ukraine und den Westen für den
mutmaßlichen Anschlag auf den
prominenten nationalistischen
Schriftsteller Sacher prelier PIN
verantwortlich es soll ein
Bombenanschlag auf das Auto prelierpins
gewesen sein der dabei schwer verletzt
wurde sein Fahrer starb prälabin hatte
schon vor Jahren für einen Angriff auf
die Ukraine geworben und dort auch an
der Seite pro russischer Separatisten
gekämpft
in Iran ist ein schwedisch iranischer
Staatsangehöriger unter dem Vorwurf
mehrere Anschläge hingerichtet worden
des berichten staatliche iranische
Medien schweden hatte gefordert das
Todesurteil nicht zu vollstrecken auch
einem Deutsch Iraner droht die
Hinrichtung ihm wird eine Verantwortung
für einen Terroranschlag und Kooperation
mit ausländischen Geheimdiensten
vorgeworfen
in Kanada sind in der Provinz Alberta im
Westen des Landes zahlreiche Waldbrände
außer Kontrolle geraten einige Feuer
erstreckten sich über tausende Hektar
berichten lokale Medien ungewöhnlich
hohe Temperaturen und starker Wind waren
die Brände an mehr als 20.000 Menschen
mussten sich laut Feuerwehr in
Sicherheit bringen
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 7 9 18 19
31 47 Superzahl 9 und weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf Lotto Punkt
zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite 557
das ist die Seite 556 die
Wetteraussichten für morgen im Nordosten
trocken und Teil sehr sonnig von
Südwesten aufkommende Schauer und ab dem
mittagteilskräftige Gewitter mit
Starkregen und Hagel 14 bis 24 Grad die
weiteren Aussichten zu Beginn der Woche
im Nordosten freundlich und trocken dann
auch dort wie auch sonst häufig
unbeständig mit Schauern und Gewittern
so viel von uns an diesem Samstagabend
mit dem Sportstudio geht's gleich weiter
und danach so gegen 025 gibt es die
nächste heute Express bis morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]